why did uh so many people go after
andrew tate i mean you've spent time
with them right i obviously uh did an
episode with them um and you know i said
to him at the end of the episode i said
look like the way that you deliver a lot
of the message uh is kind of in this
bombastic rapper and uh there's an
entertainment value to it but there's a
seat of truth in a lot of what he was
saying is it a thing where they feel
threatened by him they fear uh kind of
the truth getting out um what do you
think is going on there it's because
he's literally the anti-woke like he's
the auntie of everything that they're
promoting so i don't even think it has
anything to do with his um so-called
misogynistic views i don't really think
they're misogynistic but i don't think
it has anything to do with that i think
it has everything to do with the fact
that he's pulling people out of the
matrix so he's waking people up he's
saying nobody's coming to save you
forget that nine to five you need to
save yourself you don't need
antidepressants let me teach you how to
fight depression by yourself what does
that do puts the pharmaceutical
companies out of out of work right and
so it's because he's literally
empowering men to save themselves and i
think that men are the forefront of
society like if you have weak men
society crumbles if you have strong
women it doesn't really matter it's the
men that matter so if you have strong
men then society can flourish in every
different way um and they don't want we
like the powers that be don't want us
flourishing because less control um and
so like i personally learned so much
from him like i love self-improvement
content and so i'm i mainly watch
men mail content to be honest because
it's mainly the men that are doing that
you know he talks about happiness and
again his content is for men but i like
it so he's like um
don't worry about being happy just wake
up get up and do
keep going you know and i'm like that's
true i do i ask myself am i happy what
do i forget happiness just do take
action and that is so powerful because
if you're not happy and you're wondering
why you're not happy all day you're just
gonna be there taking your
antidepressants feeling like a zombie
demotivated compliant you'll do whatever
the system tells you to do you'll take
that vaccine because you can't be
bothered to fight because you have no
fight left in you so he's give he's he's
empowering people men in particular and
so they they can't allow that yeah if
you go back and you read uh the stoics
and then you listen to what andrew tate
was saying and you strip away the
delivery of both of them right so you
strip away kind of all of the
poetic uh kind of almost to a degree
aristocratic you know
wrapper from the stoix message and then
you take away the bombastic components
of andrew tate and you overlay them
they're saying a lot of the same stuff
like you are in control you have to
mentally get into a certain position in
order to be successful in life uh
there's not a lot of like random
[ __ ] in the world and material
possessions and things like that that
will make you happy like ultimately it's
an inside job yeah right and what cracks
me up is i think that um if you were to
take also you know will smith who is
pretty well loved around the world like
he has a viral video uh where he talks
about like happiness is an inside job
and he explicitly says it's not my job
to make my wife happy it is her job to
be happy and somehow like that was
celebrated right and so like it's very
unique because i also think it
highlights this idea of like the
messenger really matters um and one it's
easy to celebrate the dead people right
because it's like oh they're dead like
they're not they're not really
threatening anything
um two is they end up getting shared by
a lot of folks who we consider of high
status in society today so when you see
somebody tweeting about the stoics
reading books about the stoics or
whatever we end up ascribing like oh you
are of a certain status and therefore
those ideas being shared by these people
today mean that these people are good
and these ideas are like accepted but
then when you see somebody who uh
to the outsider they'd be they would say
what has andrew tate accomplished the
second that it is uh kickboxing or it is
you know internet business or any of
these other things it doesn't fit into
the mold of uh oh you rose up in the
ranks in the corporation and you became
the ceo
i actually would uh it would be
fascinating you can't study it or kind
of run the experiment but like what
happens if you took those exact same
thoughts and you had somebody from like
the accepted institutions say them what
would their response be it's interesting
because jordan peterson is also quite
like andrew tay in terms of
the message empowering men to be men and
i love jordan peterson like i'm such a
big fan um
but even they don't like him and he
comes from the institution he's a
professor he wears a three-piece suit
yeah
this guy is a suit exactly you know he
speaks impeccably well everything about
him you know um you know he's got a
great family he's still with his wife
he's not you know messing around or
anything like that it's a great man and
they hate him because that's how deep
the wokeness goes hey you did you like
this video great make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time